most of you will probably have watched
the film Forrest Gump and of course the
actor Tom Hanks character saying I just
felt like running well ha X guest he
felt the same way Rob Pope is running
from one side of America to the other
and it's all for charity I have to say
Rob Pope you look a little bit like
Forrest Gump as well did you share that
sentiment you just felt like running you
a that place to the bed like support I
still feel like running so hopefully
that'll continue for a while and you've
done this before haven't you you set off
from mobile and Alabama major all major
weight all the way across the United
States to LA now you've just decided to
up sticks turn around and do it back but
this time via 18 state how did you
choose the route well there's a couple
of key landmarks in the film sort of you
actually see him you mentioned there
later and he reaches Santa Monica Pier
and and then he turns around and you
actually see him then turning around at
Marshall Point Lighthouse in Maine which
which I've just done so I've actually
across the country twice now and I'm
just on my way back towards the west
coast again and the rest of the route
shall be taken from a map that was
speeches behind the newscaster when he
crosses the Mississippi for the fourth
time now you're a serious runner if
people can't make that out already from
what you're undertaking but you became
the Australian marathon champion in 2015
you've won the Liverpool Rock & Roll
Marathon also the same year lots of
other personal bests and are you doing
this then sort of professionally or do
you have a a cropper job as it were
normally I'm a veteran surgeon but and
hey yeah I had to like to pack that in
for a bit work work might be wondering
where I am by then I'm so you're doing
all this for charity and which charities
have you been supporting I'm running for
the World Wildlife Fund and peace direct
I chose those because there when as I
said forests across the Mississippi to
fourth time there's a small peppery port
as you say you run into women's rights
the homeless World Peace environment of
the animals and between those two
charities they actually
all of those bases I love it and you
know during the film forrest gump
often people joined him for segments of
his running have you had that or any
other kind of memorable experiences
along the road yeah I've had a few
people join me and no one's managed to
run with me for a whole day I've had a
couple of friends oh come out and sort
of either rode the bike or they've done
a couple of runs with me during a day
and my motions of memorable companion so
far I was actually a dog call there but
we named a hope and we found her in a
New Hope Arkansas and basically she
followed me for about five miles and no
houses that went past knew who she was
and so we took her into the RV which is
a little bit worrying because she had
pretty bad mange and fortunately we
didn't get it and we managed to rehome
her through our local veterinary surgery
so whenever I'm feeling a little bit bit
low I always think about hope and cheers
me up yeah